[Applaus]
[Musik]
Katar Austragungsort der Fußball-WM
auch ein paar Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer tragen im reichen Wüstenstaat
zum reibungslosen Ablauf des
umstrittenen Turniers bei einige von
ihnen leben schon lange hier
rund eine Flugstunde entfernt Dubai
offener und schillernder als Katar ein
Paradies für fremde wenn man sich an die
Regeln hält
wir begleiten fünf Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer die sich auf das Abenteuer am
Golf eingelassen haben
worin liegt der Reiz was sind die
Herausforderungen des Alltags und fühlen
Sie sich trotz des kulturunterschieds
heimisch
[Musik]
Katar im Frühsommer 2022 die WM rückt
näher für Hotelier Chris Franzen
bedeutet das rund um die Uhr Termine
heute hat der Schweizer Botschafter
eingeladen ja gut wenn man natürlich
und jetzt
jeder Tag mit am besten das Höhe hat
drei Ministers präsidents das Thema
die WM in Katar wirft ihre Schatten
voraus ein solches Turnier mit tausenden
Fans aus aller Welt will auch
diplomatisch begleitet sein
Botschafter Edgar Dörig ist sich dessen
bewusst heute findet in Doha die
Gruppenauslosung statt darum sind auch
der Präsident des schweizerischen
Fußballverbandes Dominik Blanc und
Nationaltrainer Murat Yakin angereist ja
für mich ist das auch neuer fahrig also
es geht um verschiedene Dienstleistungen
im angetrockneten Zustand Sache macht wo
dann nicht unbedingt toleriert sind und
damit bereits
unterstützend ein großes Thema ist die
Unterbringung der Fans Chris Luxushotel
soll vor allem VIP-Gäste beherbergen der
Druck rechtzeitig fertig zu werden nimmt
zu und Corona erschwert die Planung nach
wie vor
430 okay
ab 1 Juni Fahrt intensives Training an
Nationalmannschaft
sondern
auch in einer Botschaft ist der Besuch
des Nationaltrainers eine
außergewöhnliche Attraktion chris hat
einem gemeinsamen Bekannten versprochen
Murat Yakin Grüße auszurichten und ein
selfie zu machen
vom FC Liverpool will in der 70er Jahre
80 Jahre ist das die Mannschaft gesehen
natürlich als Walliser FC Sion und FC
Schaffhausen
natürlich dass das klappt toi toi toi ja
also wir haben ein Spieler dafür die für
großes gemacht sind und wieso nicht das
Überraschung etwas tolles zu bewirken
haben
ich bin fürs Fußballspielen zuständig
und das klar dass vieles natürlich auch
mit politisiert wird wir können sich
beeinflussen wir haben ja Leute dafür
die sich dafür einsetzen und so soll ich
raus auch sein wir sind für die
Teilnahme nicht für den boykord wir sind
überzeugt dass dank den Sport dann den
Fußball man kann die große Vorschritt
machen mit der Werte den Fußballen jetzt
haben wir eine kleine
Geschenk das ist die das berühmte Trikot
der Nationalmannschaft
sie spielen erst im Dezember
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
erst Mitte der 90er Jahre startete
kathar seinen Modernisierungsprozess
seitdem versucht das Emirat eine
Gratwanderung zwischen strukturellem
Wachstum und Bewahrung der Tradition
geht mit ihren Kindern oft in diesen
privaten Park hier kann die
Westschweizerin ohne Abaya hin obwohl
ihr Ehemann seid aus einer alten
katarischen Familie stammt leben sie ein
moderne Beziehung doch wird ihre Tochter
später die gleichen Freiheiten genießen
können wie corali
ich bin Europäerin aber Eier ist katari
ich bin gespannt wie mein Mann eines
Tages reagieren wird wenn jemand fragt
warum seine Tochter sich nicht bedeckt
wenn sie sich nicht bedecken möchte ist
das natürlich ihre Entscheidung eins
weiß ich er wird meiner Tochter immer
die Wahl lassen
zwei Kulturen unter einem Dach was oft
in einem Kompromiss mündet kann das
Leben auch bereichern
seit erster Besuch in dünsi dem Wohnort
von coralis Vater war ein
unvergessliches Familienabenteuer
es war toll mein Vater hat Abdul rachman
zum ersten Mal gesehen wegen Corvette
ging es ja vorher nicht
das ist tipicomi das ist ein typisches
Bild wäre ich in der Schweiz geblieben
hätte ich sicher ein ganz anderes Leben
geführt ich auf dem Traktor natürlich
mit meinem Sohn das sind tolle
Erinnerungen schau hier ist er zum
ersten Mal auf einem Pferd
[Musik]
es war großartig besonders mein Sohn in
dieser Natur zu sehen das Wetter war
natürlich ganz anders als hier das Grün
die Kühe wunderschön ich habe es richtig
genossen
ganz überzusiedeln kommt für Zeit aber
nicht in Frage
wir haben unsere Jobs hier und wir
genießen viele Vorteile haben Land hier
das würde ich im Moment nicht aufgeben
wollen
vielleicht im Ruhestand
[Musik]
die Geschäftsfrau Andrea Hirschi führt
in Dubai ein typisches expertleben auf
Zeit dazu gehört auch das Ausprobieren
von hiesigen Freizeitaktivitäten
[Gelächter]
John Bashing nennt sich ein beliebter
Offroad Spaß da solche wüstenausflüge
mit dem Auto nicht ungefährlich sind
nehmen meist mehrere Fahrzeuge Teil
außer Andreas Mann Remo ist noch eine
befreundete Familie aus Schweden dabei
jetzt lernen lufthose und zwar gerade
sehr gut das ist
viel Luft
fahren auf samt erfordert Übung hinzu
kommt es hat in den letzten Tagen
geregnet
ja
[Musik]
andrea hat eher Mühe mit solchen
luxusabenteuern aber Remo ist Offroad
erfahren und findet es lustig nee Jungs
[Musik]
die Challenge beim tune Bashing ist wie
ein Surfer am Kamm der Düne entlang zu
gleiten
wenn es nach Andrea ginge müsste das
wohl nicht unbedingt sein
[Musik]
nach dem kleinen Crashkurs zeigt Andrea
was sie gelernt hat
für das Fahrvergnügen im Sand haben sie
extra eine Vorrichtung einbauen lassen
die verhindert dass das ABS blockiert
auch wenn es nicht immer den Anschein
macht das Thema Umweltschutz ist auch in
Dubai angekommen Matteo boffer schreibt
mit nachhaltigen Start-ups gerade eine
kleine Erfolgsstory heute soll er an das
Swiss international scientific School
aus seinem Leben erzählen danke
Matthäus Mission jungen Menschen zu
zeigen dass Nachhaltigkeit nicht nur
sinnvoll ist sondern auch ein gutes
Geschäft sein kann die Teenager machen
hier einen Bacher meist als Vorbereitung
für ein Studium im Ausland
die Swiss international scientific
School ist die größte Schweizer Schule
außerhalb der Schweiz ein Unternehmer
wie Matteo zu Gast zu haben gibt den
Schülern einen Einblick in die
Geschäftswelt und darüber hinaus die
Chance ein paar praktische Erfahrungen
zu sammeln
[Musik]
good morning
business and and grow also einen Triple
Matthäus beste Geschäftsidee hatte ein
junger Mann damals kaum älter als diese
Schülerinnen und Schüler
[Musik]
bis zu 26.000 Franken pro Jahr
investieren die Eltern hier in die
Zukunft ihrer Kinder ein Netzwerker wie
Matteo kann da später nützlich sein
nur ein Prozent dieser jungen Menschen
später ein Startup im Bereich
Nachhaltigkeit soziales oder Umwelt
gründet wäre das für mich schon ein
großer Erfolg
es ist nicht nötig dass es alle machen
das wäre auch nicht realistisch aber
eine Person kann einen großen
Unterschied machen und so wiederum eine
Wirkung auf andere Menschen haben
daher wäre ein Prozent für mich schon
ein großer Erfolg
die Schweiz gehört zu Dubai Top 5
Handelspartnern Gewinnchancen verspricht
alles was mit digitaler Entwicklung und
Nachhaltigkeit zu tun hat
nach der Wirtschaftskrise 2009 stehen
alle Zeichen wieder auf Wachstum
mitgetragen wird dieser von den rund 3
Millionen Ausländern die im Emirat leben
und arbeiten
experts aus Europa die für ein paar
Jahre herkommen führen meist ein
privilegiertes Leben einzig die große
Sommerhitze macht allen zu schaffen
doch Dubai wäre nicht Dubai hätte es
nicht auch für dieses Problem eine
Lösung parat den wohl größten Hunde
Indoorspielplatz der Welt
rund 60 Franken zahlt man hier pro Tag
hohl und Bringservice inbegriffen dafür
können sich Cooper und honey auf
diversen Innen- und Außenflächen
austoben einem Areal so groß wie 18
Tennisplätze
Indoorspielplatz ist super wichtig hier
wo tönt in Dubai verschmieren
und hier Ebene hier den übernachten
für ganze Hundefamilie eigentlich
[Musik]
ein Freizeitpark nur für Hunde doch bei
allen Superlativen am Ende ist so ein
Kunstrasen eben doch nur
künstlich ja
Natur wo mehrere setzen aber das ist auf
jeden Fall hier ist 100
zurück in Katar mit der Ausrichtung der
Fußball-WM erneuert das Emirat auch
gleich die gesamte Infrastruktur
an diesem Abend findet in Dora die
Gruppenauslosung statt
auf der Gästeliste Chris und seine
australische Ehefrau Rachel
die Schweizer Botschaft hat Freunde und
Businesspartner zum Public Viewing
eingeladen
während des Turnier im Westen kritisch
gesehen wird wächst die Vorfreude in
Katar mit jedem Tag also ich hatte
wirklich schon so dass ich als
haupttellier ist man da schon
im Teamspirit euch in der meist doch
Teile von dem ganzen Projekt
Katar 2022 und
Faszination ist schon der Energie stieg
mit jedem Tag man merkt das also
chris ist ein Fußballfan jedoch kein
Fußball verrückter
als wir im Oman gelebt haben kam
Australien für ein Spiel gegen den Oman
ich habe das Spiel mit den Kindern
gesehen er wollte nicht weil es so heiß
war
einfache Gegner wären schön doch das Los
verteilt an diesem Abend keine Geschenke
[Musik]
Katar wird wegen der Arbeitsbedingungen
auf den wm-baustellen immer noch stark
kritisiert
Ritas klavi und das internationale
gewerkschaftsteam haben durch
Inspektionen und Gespräche jedoch
einiges bewirkt für heute hat die
internationale Bau- und holzgewerkschaft
bhi mit der fußball-gewerkschaft Pfiff
pro ein Fußballturnier für die Arbeiter
und Arbeiterinnen organisiert
[Musik]
football players we love football
for my Grant worker strikes so this game
ist SWAT Recall as solidarity gay was
spezielles natürlicher Katar ist das mir
hat ja schon früher so Kampagne gemacht
Südafrika Brasilien Russland aber das
haben wir Gewerkschaften vor Ort aber
jetzt da in Katha was kein
Gewerkschaften geht haben wir eigentlich
Gewerkschaftsarbeit vor der
internationalen ausgemacht und darum
sind wir da auch über selber vor Ort und
und machen die Inspektionen und treffen
die Leute und das ist schon spezielle
und es ist nicht
Probleme sind
das sind jetzt Diamanten um die es gab
das Turnier ist der Abschluss einer
zweitägigen Konferenz auf der mit dem
Arbeitsministerium über weitere Schritte
diskutiert wurde
dass sich sogar Ex-Profis wie Damiano
Tomasi engagieren hat mehrere Gründe
[Applaus]
es gab nicht
allmillionen und den Kunden oder zu dass
sie auch sehr oft sehen der pfeffere von
einer Fussballspieler sind Bauarbeiter
gesehen
und das finde ich noch so ein schönes
wichtig auch von den Verbesserungen die
die bhi in Qatar bewirkt hat profitieren
nicht nur die Bauarbeiter auf den
wm-baustellen
[Applaus]
werden Sie wahrscheinlich andere Länder
im Golf exportieren also es ist schon
mehr als nur 40.000
[Applaus]
seit 2018 kämpft die internationale
Gewerkschaft bhi für eine Verbesserung
der hiesigen Arbeitsbedingungen
Ritas Mann Hans begleitet seine Frau zum
ersten Mal nach Doha als neutraler
Beobachter er kennt das Zähringen um
jeden Zentimeter für die gute Sache
weil ja ich glaube schon dass die Arbeit
nicht vor allem
vorurteilhand oder der Schlacht sie mit
verkattern und so weitergehen
noch am Tag dieses Turniers äußert sich
ernesty international erneut über die
Situation der migrationsarbeiter in
Katar diese sei trotz der Reformen nach
wie vor kritisch
und andere Organisationen
aber man muss schon gesehen
da aktiv sein
wie nachhaltig die Reformen auch über
die WM hinaus sind muss ich erst noch
zeigen
im Hauptquartier des Supreme Committee
bereitet sich Coralie auf einen
besonderen Termin vor
in einer Ausstellung bringt sie meist
ausländischen Diplomaten die
fußball-tradition ihrer zweiten Heimat
näher
heute begrüßt Sie Rita die pr-expertin
und die Gewerkschafterin treffen sich
zum ersten Mal
[Musik]
bis 1971 war Katar britisches
Protektorat
Coralie geht in ihrer Rolle auf der Tag
der WM-Vergabe war für das ganze Land
ein Feiertag
[Gelächter]
eigentlich
when I will
als ich an diesem zweiten dezember in
der fernzone Stand und Zeugin wurde wie
Katha damals wahrscheinlich das kleinste
Land auf der Karte die Ausrichtung der
WM gewann dem größten Sportereignis
dabei stolz
als ich 91 nach Katar kam war hier Wüste
meine Kinder sind katari
eines Tages werden sie in einem der
Stadien sitzen und sagen können Mama hat
mitgeholfen das zu bauen Mama war ein
Teil davon das ist toll und eine Ehre
50 km außerhalb von Doha eine Hightech
Milchfarm mitten in der Wüste
2017 belegten die Nachbarstaaten Katar
mit einem Embargo der Vorwurf das Emirat
unterstütze radikal islamische Gruppen
Lebensmittel wurden rationiert seitdem
setzt Katha verstärkt auf
Selbstversorgung Alex
wirklich nix links und rechts
ja
Chris interessiert sich für eine
Zusammenarbeit über 400.000 Liter
Frischmilch werden hier täglich
verarbeitet und der Bedarf wird während
der WM noch steigen
CEO PT larrydes nimmt sich Zeit für
einen Rundgang
für das Know-how holte man sich Experten
aus dem Land der Cowboys
okay gut
Survivor the
movings to you
Happing
of the desert in the
Mittag
der erste hier sind importiert wurde und
Netz Handtücher hier wo hier geboren
sind
Weideland sucht man in der Wüste
vergebens die Kühe stehen auf Sand
Kühlsysteme sorgen in den Stallungen für
konstante 24°c
für den Nachwuchs sorgt man mit
künstlicher Besamung alle 30 Minuten
kommt ein Kalb zur Welt
nichts natürlich ich glaube jede Kühe
Wiener lieber von der staffelalbin
Zermatt als hier in der Wüste in Katar
bei mir ist aber verstaut dass das doch
ein City ist
für das Land dass die
Sauberkeit produzieren aber wir haben
natürlich die Vorstellung
werden und das war wahrscheinlich eine
immer so in der Schweiz sie zu Tag also
da müsste mich selber mal ein bisschen
skip
im Besucherpavillon des Supreme
Committee tauschen sich corali und Rita
weiter aus
das Thema wie so oft die Zustände auf
den stadionbaustellen
die Arbeiter speziell die Bauarbeiter
arbeiteten wirklich unter schlechten
Bedingungen als wir hier vor zehn Jahren
unsere Arbeit begannen
aber es gab Verbesserungen und wie du
richtig sagst in der Schweiz gab es in
den 60ern die saisonies die Waren in
einer ganz ähnlichen Situation
ja
natürlich kann man noch einiges
verbessern aber das ist überall auf der
Welt so aber dieser ständige Fokus die
negative Presse das nervt
weil wir viele gute Dinge machen über
die niemand berichtet
Rita hat sicher ein offenes Ohr dafür
ganz ehrlich mich persönlich riecht das
auf weil Doha mein Zuhause ist und Katha
meine Heimat
auch in der Schweiz gäbe es Sachen die
man kritisieren könnte findet die
gebürtige Westschweizerin das versteht
Rita als Kind italienische Einwanderer
gut
zwei Frauen die den
Modernisierungsprozess in Katar
mitgestalten jede auf ihre Art
zurück in Dubai andrea hat einen
wichtigen Termin auf dem Amt
die gelernte coiffeus und Geschäftsfrau
möchte gerne eine Lizenz David Garden
aus Freeland schaffen und für das muss
ich Bewilligung haben wie haben
sie immer
und ja das machen wir jetzt
das frauengeschäfte machen ist in Dubai
mittlerweile Standard trotzdem kann es
nicht schaden ein bisschen aufs Image zu
achten
[Musik]
erster Eindruck das Amt ist er eine
moderne kaffee-lounge hallo guten Morgen
[Musik]
seventy and within minutes
doch ganz so einfach ist es nicht die
digitale ID hat ihre Tücken die
Gesichtserkennung lässt Andrea nicht ins
System
genau
einfach nicht und jetzt muss ich Kiosk
updaten aber ich weiß nicht was also das
passiert hier immer und mache wieder
der Kiosk ist eine kleine Zweigstelle
der Behörde gleich nebenan
es ist der Kiosk
I need to update
die nächste Hürde um ihre ID abzudaten
braucht Andrea die Hilfe ihres Mannes
aus altem Müll neue Werte schaffen in
allem was mit Upcycling zu tun hat
scheint Matteo mitzumischen
mit einer App bei der er involviert war
wird Recycling zum Spiel Flaschen
sammeln Punkte sammeln
in Zukunft wird man die Punkte in eine
kryptowährung umtauschen können
deswegen ist es ein spaßiges System das
auch junge Menschen motiviert
Plastikflaschen zusammen und
ordnungsgemäß zu entsorgen
die Entwicklung oder der Import von
recyclingsystemen aus Europa nach Dubai
ist ein gutes business
Flaschen entsorgt Punkte gesammelt nun
können Meghan und Matteo den Abend
vorbereiten das Paar hat Freunde zum
Käsefondue eingeladen stilecht mit
Schweizer Deko und richtigem Käse
leider findet man keinen Schweizer Käse
in Dubai daher bringe ich jedes Mal wenn
ich aus dem Tessin zurückkomme
diesen supermarktkäse mit
und der kommt aus meiner Region aus
einer Käserei am Gotthard
auch nach sechs Jahren Dubai hält Matteo
an gewissen Schweizer Eigenarten Fest
eine Sache die mir an Matteo auffällt
ist wie genau er es mit der Zeit nimmt
er ist überpünktlich gibt es ein Meeting
um 6 Uhr muss er immer schon fünf vor da
sein das ist wohl sehr schweizerisch
[Musik]
es ist kein Problem ich bin zwar ganz
anders also muss ich mich da auch ein
bisschen anpassen aber ehrlich gesagt
finde ich es gar nicht schlecht die
Dinge so zu machen wie er ja
[Musik]
andrea ist ihre Arbeitserlaubnis einen
großen Schritt näher gekommen
was genau weil sie selber nicht aber so
wie es ausgesetzt besitzt es läuft
leider ist auch der Bezahlvorgang nicht
ohne Remo möglich
e
from the beginning
oh mein Gott
yes
Center
[Musik]
die geduldige Sachbearbeiterin findet
schließlich eine Lösung
Andrea kann den Bezahlvorgang später von
zu Hause aus abschließen
ihren Plänen steht nichts mehr im Weg
ins Look do I get like
Download okay perfekt
danke
und ich freue mich jetzt kann ich
offiziell Kunden
Dubai hat sich zum Hotspot für Kurztrips
aus Europa entwickelt
Matteo empfängt zwei alte Freunde aus
dem Tessin
Walter und Brian
die beiden sind ziemlich beeindruckt von
Matthäus Freizeitsport Trophäen
[Gelächter]
ich bin ist der große Vorteil unserer
Freundschaft dass es jedes Mal wenn wir
uns sehen so ist das wären wir nie
getrennt gewesen selbst dann wenn ich
mal ein paar Monate oder sogar ein Jahr
nicht in der Schweiz war
mit Freundin Julia ist die Runde
komplett
noch immer trauern alle der wegen corvit
abgesagten großen Hochzeitsfeier nach
zum Trost kann man sich ja zumindest
Matthäus romantischen Unterwasser
Heiratsantrag nochmals anschauen
[Musik]
als Matteo im Winter 2016 nach Dubai
ging kam dies für seine besten Freunde
wie aus heiterem Himmel obwohl sie
wussten dass es ihm schlecht ging
seine erste Ehe war in die Brüche
gegangen bereits ein Jahr zuvor war
seine Mutter gestorben
was als Flucht begann wurde zum Anfang
eines komplett neuen Lebens
und ganz am Anfang habe ich natürlich
gedacht unter all den Orten Dubai nein
warum gehst du ausgerechnet nach Dubai
aber natürlich ist es auch eine
Herausforderung eine sehr spannende
Challenge wie man auf Englisch sagen
würde
einer ganz anderen Kultur einer ganz
anderen Denkweise als die Schweiz die
wir ja alle kennen
und so muss ich sagen dass ich fast
stolz auf ihn war ich glaube ich hätte
es wohl genauso gemacht
so you not least
Mateo hat sein Glück in Dubai gefunden
und damit auch ein neues Zuhause
es klingt vielleicht wie ein Klischee
aber für mich gilt zu Hause ist wo das
Herz ist von die in Dubai zu essen war
für mich noch vor sieben acht oder zehn
Jahren unvorstellbar und nun bin ich
hier mit meiner Frau aus Südafrika die
ich in Dubai getroffen habe zusammen mit
meinem Besten kindheitsfreunden und eine
gemeinsamen Freundin die wir hier
kennengelernt haben das zeigt dass man
sich eine schöne Umgebung schaffen kann
wenn man bereit ist Türen aber vor allem
sein Herz zu öffnen
[Musik]
in der letzten Folge Geschäftsfrau
andrea hat es geschafft die Lizenz in
der Tasche die erste Kundin auf dem
Stuhl
außerdem Coralie und Zeit planen ihre
Zukunft in Katha doch der Bau ihres
Hauses geht schleppend voran und Chris
Franzen unter Druck wird sein Luxushotel
rechtzeitig fertig